[Music]
one of the most common mistakes I see in
interviewing is that the candidate puts
on what I call the interview mask they
shift from who they are to I am now the
ideal candidate and it almost becomes
robotic and it becomes disconnected and
we sit there in front of somebody and
we're not really us I've always brought
who I am to an interview and sometimes I
didn't get the job because of it but
isn't it better for somebody to
understand that this is who you are and
how you will interact when you're not
just sitting in that interview chair and
does it fit with the organization I went
through seven rounds with the most
impressive consulting company that you'd
ever heard of I wanted the job and I was
me and I was loose and I was you know
chatty and the feedback even after seven
rounds when they had the technical skill
remember they're only trying to figure
out three things can they do the job do
they want to do the job and will they
fit well they knew I could do the job
they knew I wanted to do the job and
they kept interviewing to try to find
this fit and it wasn't there and after I
was upset for an hour I got over it if
you understand that if you're bringing
this mask this persona that is not what
you're really going to bring to the
workforce you might end up in a role
that is not the right one for you we
often get contrary questions seeking
information that might not put us in the
best light and our idea of a great
response is to give them a fake one give
them one that looks like a strength well
I was in that position and I had my
what's your greatest weakness answer
ready delegation thinking ah I'm a doer
and I do it all myself and I presented
that and the interviewer said yeah I get
that answer all the time give me another
one
and I was a deer in the headlights and I
tried humor and I said what do you mean
I'm not perfect I had more flaws he
wouldn't let me get away with it and
what happens in those moments is that
you give a real answer and that's what I
want you to do give a real answer and I
said well if you ask my mom the question
she'll tell you that sometimes I talk
before I think
and my foot fits very well into my mouth
and it's true and I'm working on it and
then I proceeded to say here's the ways
in which I'm trying to get better at
that but I'm not there yet
if that interviewer leaves not having
the answers that they need it's very
hard to evaluate whether or not they
want to hire you so if somebody asks you
a question make sure you aren't giving
them the answer up front I always say
put the bottom line on top answer the
question and then explain it a company
would much rather have somebody who's
aware of the things that they need to
work on and know that they're working on
it then somebody who thinks I got this
all attitude over aptitude will get you
a long way another mistake that
candidates make is not recognizing when
the interview starts and when it stops
because it's not just that hour that
you're in the room that interview starts
from the moment they invite you for the
interview and sometimes even before
every interaction you have in scheduling
in the security area in the elevator in
the waiting room are all part of the
process and I love that time where
you're walking from the waiting room to
the interview room with your interviewer
that rapport building is such a key
portion of the interview and I actually
consider it the initial stage after the
interview is over that hours end and
they say goodbye it's not over we all
know about the thank-you note but I
would even tell you that when you don't
get the job it's still not over build a
relationship with that interviewer build
the relationship with the company
because maybe that job wasn't the right
one for you but maybe the next one is
get some feedback maybe you can enhance
your skills and do better at the next
interview maybe you know somebody that
you can refer in understand at the end
of the interview is not the end
[Music]